yeah he went to welcome this video plane
in its yacht Yvonne yeah I hope the
sound is fine I have the window opened
something that I usually don't do while
recording but it's so hot that um I
think it makes sense to do okay so he
plays a bit of a weird opening here you
know to be three is uncommon okay I'll
do something conservative
you know I don't think I can take care -
unfortunately
c7 that is probably hanging for real
mm-hmm
I wonder if he thinks is this a bullet
game he's not even taking a second for
his moves
no he takes time YUM
I just wanted to provoke this move it's
not a huge thing but not bad not bad to
have a hook for b5 before maybe even
though he will probably play Knight c3
and then b5 will be M yeah close to
impossible to play
yeah what is he doing here 93 looks
extremely natural even though it is
certainly not the only move I'm
attacking you for some I'm a little bit
irritated because I see you butts like
handling this like a bullet game and now
he's falling asleep
it's really hard
he's online you can the Green Dot
indicates this I think just join to the
game yeah no clue I mean that's
certainly some sort of issue it's not
just it's not just him thinking and now
we made a move yeah I don't know what
yeah b5 I would love to do this but I
cannot really get b5 going
mmm I even dislike but should be six now
with hindsight
Knight is seven and b5 and that looks
really oh it doesn't look right but I
don't like my position I don't know what
what what did I do wrong
I'm not a not entirely certain what my
mistake was him
yeah I know it looks strange but I need
to get night a seven and initiate some
sort of play push the bishop back play
b5 f5 f6 now is a threat
yeah I can do that f5 9595 Bishop d7 and
back it should I'm not happy am but I
shouldn't lose immediately no actually
f5 I can go Bishop c4 which is a little
bit stronger
okay if I take the night what's
happening I mean not much I think but
take this there is a check with just one
check it cannot be a huge problem
yeah Bishop to d7 I guess
oops yeah
the f6 is okay I was just thinking I've
had something more convincing even
beyond resigned it was really Audia with
the long things maybe the air he got
disturbed or and what I had sometimes I
hear someone knocking on the door
I didn't like my position at all Queen T
3 is an odd move
maybe maybe Bishop before isn't isn't
isn't even the best they normally go to
e3 yeah this is a move that the engine
suggests I thought about it briefly it
is fairly logical I like to do this with
tempo and you have to try to get this in
you know Bishop f4 really weird stuff
yeah I don't know maybe you should not
be too ambitious I mean white will not
have an advantage here anyhow but the
way it turned out that wasn't too bad
no b5 even by half the comp that is a
really good move at least like first
impression it makes a good that looks
good yeah if then Knight takes e4 is
hanging on 95 is strong looks like
winning Wow yeah I would I would have
expected this but in the end that is
indeed a bit of an issue here like this
so b5 is interesting okay Knight b5 is
cooperative Bishop g5 instead
interesting interesting
yeah so we got this and I'm very
surprised that I got into into these
issues before was hanging but I didn't
think I could take f3 yeah I was
thinking and somehow it looks looks too
vulnerable the engine I didn't see that
but this is an option in the first place
it doesn't seem to be so great as you
can see from the evaluation yeah Adam
the rook is certainly yeah all over the
place and now it you give up the night
ahead strange ok a five is a normal of a
3 ok I go back and now I mean maybe
maybe yeah the engine goes here and then
to see if I that is stronger it is
really stronger this way I have some
pressure against the pawn and I have at
least ideas of pushing Bishop d7 would
be 85 or c6 b5 if you can justify
technically that d6 is hanging and that
it looks better than the knight c6 here
this was really not that was not a nice
position at all
look g1 with a clear advantage this is
not good just isn't good yeah Knight is
7 and he should just go back like he go
back to me too and just be better I was
my idea was to play some b5 but it is
definitely going to be yeah
but did you say risky but this is too
nice it looks awful and that's all for
now so I was in deep deep trouble and
that probably does not work but this is
not for an advantage I can take only six
that's what I expected
Jim it's probably over land wide
resigned hmm yeah a bit of an odd game
I am definitely did not take full
advantage of the of the move order with
Queen d3 or this particular line with
Queen III okay thanks for watching